Thomas what is this
ejected
[Applause]
[Applause]
wait Isiah Thomas just got ejectives
that we're seeing that both get ejected
it looks like I've seen two tossing of
the hands like get out of here get out
of here so now they're gonna go review
it alright let's see this replay here
I'd see put his hands on Murat Koga yeah
was a bit of a shove and they're gonna
look at this replay but they'll push
them or I don't know I think that might
be probably incentive of what IT is
trying to argue there's he's wrapped up
with mellow right here and it the
momentum of mellow
[Applause]
from that angle it looks like it was a
little bit of both so when I'm sitting
there looking for a hostile act towards
a referee what I'm seeing right here is
that it was just Isiah Thomas number
four who's been adjusted and you see
Melos reaction right there
yeah I mean whenever you make contact
what official it's an automatic ejection
and depending on the the level of it I
mean it's always under review for
possible suspension Isiah Thomas has
already been suspended two games this
year for going into the crowd in
Philadelphia and now he's dealing with
this this is not even 90 seconds into
the game and it looks like Scott Brooks
is trying to argue for his player
already under man without Bradley Beal
Wow Isiah Thomas has been ejected
88 seconds into the game for what
they're calling a hostile act to an
official and where the Wizards are right
now with all the injuries and
much-needed scorn cannot see this
happening and they don't you don't want
this it's not in the best interest of
the Wizards to lose Isaiah Thomas
tonight
so if Smith getting up off the bench
much earlier then he anticipated Scott
Brooks just looking on in bewilderment
Damian Lillard shoots the technical